okay hi everyone okay let's get started
great to see you all here welcome back
for week 2 our CS 224 in so so this is a
little preview of what's coming up in
the class for this week and next week
you know this week is perhaps the worst
week of this class so in week two of the
class our hope is to actually kind of go
through some of the nitty-gritty of
neural networks and how they're trained
and how we can learn good neural
networks by backpropagation which means
in particular we're going to be sort of
talking about the training algorithms
and doing calculus to work out gradients
for improving them so we'll look a bit a
little bit word window classification
named entity recognition so there's a
teeny bit of natural language processing
in there but basically sort of week two
is sort of math of deep learning and
neural network models and sort of really
knew all Network fundamentals but the
hope is that that will give you kind of
good understanding of how these things
really work and will give you all the
information you need to do the coming-up
homework and so then in week 3 we kind
of flip so then week three is going to
be mainly about natural language
processing so we're then going to talk
about how to port syntactic structures
over sentences for building dependency
parsers of sentences which is then
actually what's used in homework 3 so
we're chugging along rapidly and then
we'll talk about this idea of the
probability of a sentence which leads
into neural language models so on the
homeworks homework 1 was due
approximately two minutes ago so I hope
everyone has submitted their homework
one I mean as one just sort of add
in general I thought you know homework 1
we hope you found was a good warm-up and
not too too hard and so it really be
best to get homework 1 in quickly rather
than to burn lots of your late days
doing homework 1 and now right now out
on the website there's homework too so
we're chugging along
so homework 2 kind of corresponds to
this week's lectures so on the first
part of it
we are expecting you to grind through
some math problems of working out
gradient derivations and then the second
part of it is then implementing your own
version of word Tyvek making use of
numpy and so this time sort of writing a
Python program it's no longer an I
Python notebook encourage you to get
early look at the materials on the web I
mean in particular corresponding to
today's lecture there's some quite good
tutorial materials that are available on
the website and so also encourage you to
look at those more generally just to
make a couple more comments on things I
mean I guess this is true of a lot of
classes at Stanford but you know when we
get the course reviews for this class we
always get the full spectrum from people
who say the class is terrible and it's
way too much work to people who say it's
a really great class one of their
favorite classes at Stanford
obviously instructors care etc and I
mean probably this reflects that we get
this very wide range of people coming to
take this class or on the one hand on
the right-hand margin perhaps we have
the physics PhDs and on the left-hand
margin we have some frosh who think this
will be fun to do anyway
we welcome it we welcome everybody but
in principle this is a graduate level
class you know that doesn't mean we want
to fail people out we'd like everyone to
succeed but also like graduate level
class we'd like you to here take some
initiative in your success meaning if
there are things that you need to know
to do the assignments and you don't know
them then you should be taking some
initial
to find some tutorials come to office
hours and talk to people and get any
help you need and learn to sort of for
any holes in your knowledge okay so
here's the plan for today so that was
the course information update so you
know this is sort of in some sense you
know machine learning neural nets intro
just to try and make sure everyone is up
to speed on all this stuff so talk a
little bit about classification
introduced neural networks little detour
and named entity recognition in sort of
show a model of doing window would
window classification and then at the
end part we sort of then dive deeper
into what kind of tools we need to learn
neural networks and so today we're going
to go through somewhere between review
and primer of matrix calculus and then
that will lead into next times lecture
where it's talking more about back
propagation and computation graphs so
yeah so this material especially the
part at the end you know for some people
it'll seem really babyish if it's the
kind of stuff you do every week for
other people it might seem impossibly
difficult but hopefully for a large
percentage of you in the middle this
will be kind of a useful review of doing
this kind of matrix calculus and the
kind of things that we hope that you can
do on homework 2 ok so yeah so sorry if
I'm boring some people if you set
through 229 last quarter you saw what a
classifier was like and hopefully this
will seem familiar but I'm just sort of
hoping to try and have everyone in week
2 sort of up to speed and I'm roughly
the same page so here's our
classification setup so we have assumed
we have training data set where we have
these vector X of our X points and then
for each of one of them we have a class
so the inputs might be words or
sentences documents or
something there a d-dimensional vector
the weii are the labels or classes that
we want to classify - and we've got a
set of c classes that we're trying to
predict and so those might be something
like the topic of a document the
sentiment positive or negative of a
document or later we'll look a bit more
named entities okay so if we have that
for this sort of intuition is we've got
this vector space of which we again have
a 2d picture and we have points in that
vector space which correspond to our X
items and what we'd want to do is look
at the ones and our training sample and
see which ones are green and red for our
two classes here and then we want to
sort of learn a line that could divide
between the green and the red ones as
best as possible and that learn'd line
is our classifier so on traditional
machine learning or statistics we have
the sort of X I vectors or our data
items that are purely fixed but we're
going to then multiply those X I by some
estimated weight vector and that
estimated weight vector will then go
into a classification decision and the
classifier that I'm showing here is a
soft max classifier which is almost
identical but not quite to a logistic
regression classifier which you should
have seen in CS 109 or a stats class or
something like that which is giving a
probability of different classes okay
and in particular if you've got a soft
max classifier or a logistic distich
regression classifier these are what
accordin linear classifiers so the
decision boundary between two classes
here is a line in some suitably high
dimensional space so it's a plane or a
hyperplane once you've got a bigger X
vector okay so here's our soft max
classifier and there are sort of two
parts to that so in the
in the weight matrix W we have a row
corresponding to each class and then for
that row we're sort of dot producting it
with our data point vector X I and
that's giving us a kind of a score for
how likely it is that the example
belongs to that class and then we're
running that through a softmax function
and just as we saw in week one this
softmax takes a bunch of numbers and
turns them into a probability
distribution does that make sense to
people people remember that from last
week good so far okay
I'm not going to go through this in
detail but I mean essentially this is
what a logistic regression does as well
the difference is that here in this
setup we have a weight vector for each
class whereas what the statisticians do
in logistic regression is they say wait
that gives us one more number of weight
vectors than we really need we can get
away but for C classes we can get away
with C minus one weight vectors so in
particular if you're doing binary
logistic regression you only need one
weight vector whereas this softmax
regression formulation you've actually
got two weight vectors one for each
class so there's that some little
difference there which we could get into
but basically the same let's just say
it's we either doing softmax or logistic
regression doesn't matter so when we're
training what we want to do is we want
to be able to predict the correct class
and so the way we're going to do that is
we're going to want to train our model
so it gives us highest probability as
possible to the correct class and
therefore it'll give us lo a probability
play as possible to the wrong classes
and so our criterion for doing that is
we're going to create this negative log
probability
the of our assignments and then we're
going to want to minimize the negative
log probability which corresponds to
maximizing the log probability which
corresponds to maximizing the
probability and but sort of pretty soon
now we're going to start doing more
stuff with deep learning frameworks in
particular PI torch and you can discover
in that that there's actually a thing
called nll loss which stands for
negative log likelihood loss but
basically no one uses that because the
more convenient thing to use is what's
called the cross entropy loss and so
you'll hear everywhere that we're
training with cross entropy loss so I
just wanted to briefly mention that and
explain what's going on there so the
concept of cross entropy comes from baby
information theory which is about the
amount of information theory I know so
we're assuming that there's some true
probability distribution P and our model
we've built some probability
distribution Q that's what we've built
with our softmax regression and we want
to have a measure of whether our
estimated probability distribution is
the good one and the way we do it and
cross entropy is we go through the
classes and we say what's the
probability of the class according to
the true model using that weighting we
then work out the log of the probability
according to our estimated model and we
sum those up and negate it and that is
our cross entropy measure okay but so
this in general gives you a measure of
sort of information between
distributions but in our particular case
remember that for each example we've
sort of assuming that this is a piece of
label training data so we're saying for
that example the right answer is class
seven so therefore our true distribution
our P is for this example
class seven with probability one and its
class
anything else with probability zero so
if you think about then what happens
with this formula you've got this
summation over all the classes but P of
C is gonna be either one or zero and
it's going to be one only for the true
class here and so what you're left with
is this is going to equal minus the log
of you see for the true class which is
sort of what we were then computing in
the previous slide okay so that's what
yeah so that's basically where you get
with cross-entropy
loss but one other concept to mention so
when you have a full data set of a whole
bunch of examples the cross-entropy loss
is then taking the per example average
so I guess that's what information
theory people sometimes call the cross
entropy rate so additionally factored in
there if you're training it on in
examples is that one on in factor that's
coming in there okay okay so that's
cross entropy loss that okay yeah
there's some mixture of the actual
levels in the ground sure right so the
simplest case is that your gold data
someone has Hanway water and they've
labeled one and the rest of zero there
you can think of cases where that isn't
the case I mean one case is you could
believe that human beings sometimes
don't know the right answer so if human
beings serum I'm not sure whether this
should be class three or four you can
imagine that we can make training data
where we put probability 1/2 on both of
them and that wouldn't be a crazy thing
to do and so then you have a true cross
entropy loss using more of a
distribution the case where it's much
more commonly used in actual practice is
there are many circumstances in which
people want to do semi-supervised
learning so I guess
a topic that both my group and Chris
raised group have worked on quite a lot
where we don't actually have fully
labeled data but we've got some means of
guessing what the labels of the data are
and if we try to guess labels of data
well then quite often we'll say here's
this data item it's two-thirds chance as
this label but it could be these other
four labels and we'd use a probability
distribution and yeah then it's more
general cross-entropy loss okay right so
that's cross-entropy loss pretty good
with this bottom bits a little bit
different which is the say whoa Nelly
this is the sort of the full data set
the other thing to notice when we have a
fool that we can have a full data set of
X's and then we have a full set of
weights we're here we're working a row
vector for the weights for one class but
we're going to work it out for all
classes so we can sort of simplify what
we're writing here and we can sort of
use matrix notation and just work
directly in terms of the matrix W okay
so for traditional ML optimization our
parameters are these sets of weights for
the different classes so for each of the
classes we have a d-dimensional row
vector of weights because we're going to
sort of dot product with our d
dimensional input vector so we have C
times D items and our W matrix and those
the parameters of our model and so if we
want to learn that model using the ideas
of gradient descents it's the casted
gradient descent we're going to do sort
of what we started to talk about last
time we have these set of parameters we
work out the gradient the partial
derivatives of all of these of the loss
with respect to all of these parameter
and we use that to get a gradient update
on our loss function and we move around
the W's and moving around the W's
corresponds to sort of moving this line
that separates between the classes and
we fiddle that around so as to minimize
our loss which corresponds to choosing a
line that best separates between the
items of the classes in some sense okay
so that's a basic classifier so the
first question is well how are things
going to be different with a neural
network classifier and so the essential
observation is that sort of most of the
classic classifiers that people used a
lot of the time so that includes things
like naive Bayes models basic support
vector machines softmax or logistic
regressions they're sort of fairly
simple classifiers in particular those
are all linear classifiers which are
going to classify by drawing a line or
in the high dimensional space by drawing
some kind of plane that separates
examples and having a simple classifier
like that can be useful in certain
circumstances I mean that gives you what
in machine learning as a high biased
classifiers there's lots of talk of in
CS 229 but if you have a data set that's
like this you can't do a very good job
at classifying all the points correctly
if you have a high bias classifier
because you're gonna only draw a line so
you'd like to have a more powerful
classifier and essentially what's been
powering a lot of the use of deep
learning is that in a lot of cases when
you have natural signals so those are
things like speech language images and
things like that you have a ton of data
so you could learn a quite sophisticated
classifier but representing the classes
in terms of the input
data is sort of very complex you could
never do it by just drawing a line
between the two classes and so you'd
like to use some more complicated kind
of classifier and so neural networks the
multi-layer neural networks that were
going to be staying to get into now
precisely what they do is provide your
way to learn very complex you know
almost limitless in fact classifiers so
that if you look at the decisions that
they're making in terms of the original
space they can be learning cases like
this I put the I put the pointer on a
couple of the slides here this this is a
visualization that was done by andraka
pothi he was a PhD student here until a
couple of years ago so this is a little
JavaScript app that you can find off his
website and it's actually a lot of fun
to play with to see what kind of
decision boundaries you can get a neural
net to come up with okay so for getting
for getting more advanced classification
out of a neural net used for natural
language there are sort of two things
going that you can do that I want to
talk about which are in in some sense
the same thing when it comes down to it
but I'll sort of mention them separately
at the beginning that one of them is
that we have these word vectors and then
the second one is that we're going to
build deeper multi-layer networks okay
so at first crucial difference that we
already started to see with what we were
doing last week is rather than sort of
having a word being this is the word
house we instead say house is a vector
of real numbers and what we can do is
change the vector that corresponds to
house in such a way as we can build
better classifiers which means that
we're going to be sort of moving how
as representation around the space to
capture things that were interested in
like word similarity analogies and
things like that so this is actually you
know kind of a weird idea compared to
conventional steps or m/l so rather than
saying we just have the parameters W we
also say that all of these word
representations are also parameters of
our model so we're actually going to
change the representations of words to
allow our classifiers to do better
so we're simultaneously changing the
weights and we're changing the
representation of words and we're
optimizing both of them at once to try
and make our model as good as possible
and so this is the sense in which people
often talk about for deep learning
models that we're doing representation
learning all right I sort of said there
are two ways I was going to mention two
things ones this sort of word vector
representation learning and then the
second one is that we're going to start
looking at deeper multi-layer neural
networks sort of hidden over here on the
slide is the observation that really you
can think of would word vector embedding
as just putting your having a model with
one more neural network layer so if you
imagine that each word was a one hot
vector with four the different word
types in your model so you had a you
know 150,000 dimensional vector with
this or one hot encoding of different
words then you could say you have a map
a matrix L which is sort of your lexicon
matrix and you will pass your one hot
vector for a word through a layer of
neural net which multiplies the one hot
vector or L and the one hot vector and
since this is a one hot vector what that
will have the effect of doing is taking
out a column of L and so really we've
got an extra layer of matrix in our new
own
and we're learning the parameters of
that matrix in the same way as we're
learning a deep neural network for other
purposes so mathematically that
completely makes sense and that's sort
of a sensible way to think about what
you're doing with word embeddings and
neural networks and implementation wise
this makes no sense at all and no one
does this because it just doesn't make
sense to do a matrix multiply when the
result of the matrix multiply will be
okay this is word ID seventeen sort of
then constructing a one hot vector of
length 150,000 with the one in position
17 and then doing a matrix multiply it
makes no sense you just take out the
column or or the row as we've discussed
seventeen of your matrix and that's what
everyone actually does okay
here's my one obligatory picture of
neurons for the class so don't miss it
I'm not gonna show it again in all class
okay so the origins of neural networks
was in some sense to try and construct
an artificial neuron that seemed to in
some sense kind of capture the kind of
computations that go on in human brains
and it's a very loose analogy for what
was produced but you know our model here
is these are our this is a teeny part of
our human brain so here are neurons this
is a neuron cell here and so what does a
neuron consist of so up the back it's
got these dendrites lots of dendrites
then it's got a cell body and if there's
stuff coming in on the dendrites the
cell body will become active and then
it'll all start spiking down this long
thing which is called the axon and so
then these axons lead to the dendrites
of a different cell or lots of different
cells right this one
that's right shown but some of these are
kind of going to different cells and so
you then have these sort of terminal
buttons
the Exxon which are kind of close to the
dendrites but have a little gap in them
and some minute miracles of biochemistry
happen there and so that's the synapse
across which you'll then have sort of
activation flowing which goes into the
next neuron so that was the starting off
model that people wanted to try and
simulate in computation so people came
up with this model of an artificial
neuron so that we have things coming in
from other neurons at some level of
activation so that's a number X 0 X 1 X
2 then sine APS's vary depending on how
excitable they are as to how easily
they'll let signal cross across the
synapse and so that's being modeled by
multiplying them by a weight W 0 W 1 W 2
and then the cell body sort of correctly
is sort of summing this amount of
excitation it's getting from the
different dendrites and then it can have
its own bias as to how likely it is to
fire that's the B so we get that and
then it has some overall kind of
threshold or propensity for firing so we
sort of stick it through an activation
function which is sort of will determine
a firing rate and that will be the
signal that's going out on the output
axon so that was sort of the starting
point of that but you know really for
what we've ended up computing we just
have a little bit of baby math here
which actually looks very familiar to
the kind of baby math you see in linear
algebra and statistics and so it's
really no different so in particular a
neuron can very easily be a binary
logistic regression unit so that this is
sort of for a logistic regression you're
taking for your input X you're
multiplying it by weight vector you're
adding your bias term and then you're
putting it through and
linearity like the logistic function and
then so you're calculating a logistic
regression inside this sort of neuron
model and so this is the this is the
difference between the softmax and the
logistic regression as I saying that
whereas the softmax for two classes has
two sets of parameters this sort of just
has one set of parameters z and you're
modeling the two classes by giving the
probability of one class from zero to
one depending on where the input to the
logistic regression is highly negative
or highly positive okay so really we can
just say these artificial neurons are
sort of like binary logistic regression
units or we can make variants of binary
logistic regression units by using some
different F function and we'll come back
to that again pretty soon okay well so
that gives us one neuron so one neuron
is a logistic regression unit for
current purposes so crucially what we're
wanting to do with neural networks to
say well why only run one logistic
regression why don't we run a whole
bunch of logistic regressions at the
same time so you know here our inputs
and here's our little logistic
regression unit but we could run three
logistic regressions at the same time or
we can run any number of them well
that's good but sort of for conventional
training of a statistical model we'd
sort of have to determine for those
orange outputs of the logistic
regression you know what we're training
each of them to try and capture with
have to have data to predict what
they're going to try and capture and so
the secret of sort of then building
began neural networks is to say we don't
actually want to decide ahead of time
what those little orange logistic
regressions are trying to capture we
want the neural network to self organize
so that
those orange logistic regression units
learn something useful and well what is
something useful
well our idea is to say we do actually
have some tasks that we want to do so we
we have some tasks that we want to do so
maybe we want to sort of decide whether
a movie review is positive or negative
something like sentiment analysis or
something like that there is something
we want to do at the end of the day and
we're going to have a logistic
regression classifier they're telling us
positive or negative but the inputs to
that aren't going to directly be
something like words in the document
they're going to be this intermediate
layer of logistic regression units and
we're going to train this whole thing to
minimize our cross entropy lost and
essentially what we're going to want to
have happen and the backpropagation
algorithm will do for us is to say you
things in the middle it's your job to
find some useful way to calculate values
from the underlying data such that it'll
help our final classifier make a good
decision and I mean in particular you
know back to this picture you know the
final classifier it's just a linear
classifier a soft max or a logistic
regression it's going to have a line
like this but if the intermediate
classifiers they are like a word
embedding they can kind of sort of
re-rent the space and shift things
around so they can learn to shift things
around in such a way as you're learning
a highly nonlinear function of the
original input space okay and so at that
point it's simply a matter of saying
well why stop there maybe you'd get even
better if we put in more layers and this
sort of gets us into the area of deep
learning and sort of precisely this is
that sort of there was they've sort of
been three
cummings of neural networks as the first
work in the 50s which is essentially
when people had a model of a single
neuron like this and then only gradually
worked out how it related to more
conventional statistics and there was
the second version of neural networks
which saw the 80s and early 90s where
people built neural networks like this
that had this one hidden layer where a
representation could be learned in the
middle but at that time it really wasn't
effective of or people weren't able to
build deeper networks and get them to do
anything useful so you sort of had these
neural networks at one hidden layers and
so precisely with research that started
in into deep learning that precisely the
motivating question is we believe we'll
be able to do even more sophisticated
classification for more complex tasks
things like speech recognition and image
recognition if we could have a deeper
network which will be able to more
effectively learn more sophisticated
functions of the input which will allow
us to do things like recognize sounds of
a language how could we possibly train
such a network so it all works
effectively and that's the kind of thing
we'll go on to more so starting this
lecture more so in the next lecture but
before we get to there just to underline
it again so once we have something like
this as our layer of a neural network we
have a vector of inputs we have a vector
of outputs and everything is connected
so that we've got this sort of weights
along every one of these black lines and
so we can say a1 is you're taking
weights times each component of x1 and
adding a biased and then you're going to
be running which is sort of this part
and then running it through
our non-linearity and that will give us
an output and we're going to do that for
each of a 1 a 2 and a 3 so again we can
kind of regard a is a vector and we can
kind of collapse it into this matrix
notation for working out the fix of
layers so fully connected layers are
effectively matrices of weights and
commonly we write them like this where
we have the bias term as a vector of
bias terms there's sort of a choice
there you can either have an always-on
input and then the bias terms become
part of the weights of our slightly
bigger matrix of one extra one extra
either column or row one extra row right
or you can just sort of have them
separately written as bees okay and then
the final note here right so once we've
calculated this part we always put
things through non-linearity which is
referred to as the activation function
and so something like the logistic
transform I showed earlier is an
activation function and this is written
as sort of vector import activation
function giving a vector output and what
this always means is that we apply this
function element-wise so we applying the
logistic function which is sort of a
naturally a 1 input 1 output function
like the little graph I showed before so
when we apply that to a vector we apply
it to each element of the vector element
wise ok we will come back very soon to
sort of saying more about nonlinearities
and what nonlinearities people actually
use but you know something you might be
wondering is well why does he always
have these nonlinearities and say there
has to be an F function there you know
why don't we just
calculate Z equals WX plus B in one
layer and then go on to another layer
that also does z2 equals W to z1 plus B
and keep on going with layers like that
and there's a very precise reason for
that which is if you want to have a
neural network learn anything
interesting you have to stick in some
function f which is a nonlinear function
such as the logistic curve I showed
before and the reason for that is that
if you're sort of doing linear
transforms like W X plus B and then W to
z1 plus B w3 z2 plus B and you're doing
a sequence of linear transforms well
multiple linear transforms just composed
to become a linear transform right so
one linear transform is rotating and
stretching the space somehow and you can
rotate them stretch the space again but
the result of that it's just one bigger
rotate and stretch of the space so you
don't get any extra power for a
classifier by simply having multiple
linear transforms but as soon as you
stick in almost any kind of
non-linearity then you get additional
power and so you know for in general
what we're doing when we're doing deep
networks in the middle of them we're not
thinking oh it's really important to
have non-linearity thinking about
probabilities or something like that our
general picture is well we want to be
able to do effective function
approximation or curve fitting we'd like
to learn a space like this and we can
only do that if we're sort of putting in
some nonlinearities which allow us to
learn these kind of curvy decision
patterns and so so if F is used
effectively for doing accurate function
approximation or sort of pattern
matching as you go along okay I think
I'm behind already okay so that was the
intro to baby neural networks all good
any questions yes you have feature one
and feature four if you multiply them
together it's highly indicative of like
the label why can you get to that
product relationships yeah good question
so in conventional steps you have your
basic input features and when people are
building something like a logistic
regression model by hand people often
say well something that's really
important for classification is looking
at the pair of feature four and feature
seven the you know if both of those are
true at the same time something
important happens and so that's referred
to normally in stats as an interaction
term and you can by hand air add
interaction terms to your model so
essentially a large part of the secret
here is having these intermediate layers
they can learn build interaction terms
by themselves yeah so it's sort of
automating the search for higher order
terms that you want to put into your
model okay I'll go on other questions
okay so yeah so here's a brief little
interlude on a teeny bit more of NLP
which is sort of a kind of problem we're
going to look at for a moment so this is
the task of named entity recognition
that I very briefly mentioned last time
so if we have some text right wasn't
piripi
okay okay if we
have some text something that in all
sorts of places people want to do is
they'd like to find the names of things
that are mentioned and then normally as
well as finding the names of things
you'd actually like to classify them so
it's like to say some of them are
organization some of them are people
some of them are places and so you know
this has lots of users you know people
like to track mentions of companies and
people and newspapers and things like
that people when they do
question-answering that a lot of the
time the answers to questions what we
call named entities the names of people
locations organizations pop songs movie
names all of those kind of things are
named entities and if you want to sort
of start building up a knowledge base
automatically from a lot of text well
what you normally want to do is get out
the named entities and get out relations
between them so this is a common task so
how can we go about doing that and a
common way of doing that is to say well
we're going to go through the words one
at a time and they're going to be words
that are in a context just like they
were forward to back and what we're
going to do is run a classifier and
we're going to assign them a class so
we're going to say first word is
organization second words organization
third word isn't a named entity fourth
word as a person fifth word as a person
and continue down so we're running a
classification of a word within a
position in the text so it's got
surrounding words around it and so to
say what the entities are many entities
are multi word terms and so the simplest
thing you can imagine doing is just say
well take the sequence that are all
classified the same and call that be it
intuition gong or something like that
there's a reason why that's slightly
defective and so what people often use
is that Biao encoding that I show on the
right but I'll just going to run ahead
and not do that now
so it might seem at first that named
entity recognition is trivial because
you know you have company names Google
and Facebook or company names and
whenever you see Google or Facebook you
just say company and how could you be
wrong but in practice there's a lot of
subtlety and it's easy to be wrong a
named entity recognition so this is so
just some of the hard cases so it's
often hard to work out the boundaries of
an entity so on this sentence First
National Bank donate donate two vans to
future school of Fort Smith so there's
presumably the name of a bank there but
is it National Bank and the first is
just the first word of a sentence which
is capitalized here like first she
ordered some food or something so kind
of unclear what it is sometimes it's
hard to know whether something's an
entity at all so at the end of this
sentence is future school the name of
some exciting kind of 21st century
school or is it just meaning it's a
future school that's going to be built
in this town right is it an entity or
not at all working out the class of an
entity is often difficult so to find out
more about Zig Ziglar and Reid features
by you know what class is exhibiting you
don't know I was actually a person's
name and there are various entities that
are ambiguous right so Charles Schwab in
text is 90% of the time and organization
name because there's Charles Schwab
brokerage but in this particular
sentence here in Woodside where Larry
Ellison and Charles Schwab can live
discreetly among wooded estates that is
then a reference to Charles Schwab the
person so it's sort of a fair bit of
understanding variously that's needed to
get it right okay so what are we going
to do with that and so this suggests
what we want to do is build classifiers
for language that work inside a context
so you know in general it's not very
interesting classifying a word out
out of context we don't actually do that
much in NLP but once you're in a context
there it's interesting to do and named
entity recognition as one case there are
lots of other places that comes up I
mean here's a slightly cool one that
there are some words that can mean
themselves and their opposite at the
same time right so to sanction something
can either mean to allow something or it
can mean to punish people who do things
or to seed something can either mean to
plant seeds and things so you're seeding
the soil or it can take seeds out of
something like a watermelon right you
just need to know the context as to
which it is okay so that suggests the
task that we can classify a word in its
context of neighboring words and any
hours an example of that and the
question is how might we do that and a
very simple way to do it might be to say
well we have a bunch of words in a row
which each have a word vector from
something like word to Veck maybe we
could just average those word vectors
and then classify the resulting vector
and the problem is that doesn't work
very well because you lose position
information you don't actually know
anymore which of those word vectors is
the one that you're meant to be
classifying so a simple way to do better
than that is to say well why don't we
make a big vector of a word window so
here are words and they each have a word
vector and so to classify the middle
word in a context of here plus or minus
two words we're simply going to
concatenate these five vectors together
and say now we have a bigger vector and
let's build a classifier over that
vector so we're classifying this X
window which is then a vector in our 5d
if we're using d dimensional word
vectors and we can do that in the kind
of way that we did previously which is
that
we could say okay for that big vector
we're going to learn W weights and we're
putting going to put it through a
softmax classifier and then we're going
to do the decisions that's a perfectly
good way to do things and for the
purpose of what I want to get to in the
last part of this is to start looking at
my matrix calculus and you know we could
use this model and do a classifier and
learn the weights of it and indeed for
the handout on the website that we
suggest you look at it does do it with
the softmax classifier of precisely this
kind but for the example I do in class I
try to make it a bit simpler and I want
to do this I think very quickly because
I'm fast running out of time so one of
the famous early papers of neural NLP
was this paper by Cola bear in Weston
which was first an icy ml paper in 2008
which actually just a couple of weeks
ago won the ICML 2018 test of time award
and then at there's a more recent
journal version of a 2011 and they use
this idea of window classification to
assign classes like named entities turn
to words in context but they did it in a
slightly different way so what they said
is well we've got these windows and this
is one with their location named entity
in the middle and this is one without a
location entity in the middle and so
what we want to do is have a system that
returns a score and it should return a
high score just as a real number in this
case and it can should return a low
score if it if there isn't a location
named in the middle of the window in
this case and so explicitly the model
just returned the score and so if you
had the top level of your neural network
a-and you just then dot-product it with
a vector you you then kind of with that
final dot product you just return a real
number and they used that as the basis
of their classifier so in full glory
what you had is you had this window of
words you looked up a word vector for
each word you then multiplied that
they've all you can concatenated the
word vectors for the window you
multiplied them by a matrix and added a
bias to get a second hidden layer which
is a and then you multiply that by a
final vector and that gave you a score
for the window and you wanted the score
to be large if it was the location and
small if it wasn't a location so in this
sort of pretend example where we have
four-dimensional word vectors that's
meaning you know for the window this is
a 20 by 1 vector for calculating the
next hidden layer we've got an 8 by 20
matrix plus a bias vector then we've got
this sort of 8 dimensional second hidden
layer and then we're computing a final
real number okay and so crucially this
is an example of what the question was
about we've put in this extra layer here
right we could have just said here's a
word vector a big word vector of context
let's just stick a softmax or logistic
classification on top to say yes or no
for location but by putting in that
extra hidden layer precisely this extra
hidden layer can calculate nonlinear
interactions between the input word
vectors so it can calculate things like
if the first word is a word like Museum
and the second and the second words a
word like the preposition in or around
then that's a very good signal that this
should be location in the middle
position of the window so extra layers
are a neural network let us calculate
these kind of interaction terms between
our basic features
okay so there was a few more slides here
that sort of go through the details of
their model but I'm gonna just skip
those for now because I'm a little bit
behind and at the end of it we've just
got this score so this is our model
which is the one that I just outlined
where we're calculating the score and
we're wanting a big score for a location
and so what we're going to want to do is
consider how we can use this model to
learn our parameters and a neural
network so in particular remember it's
the same story we've had before we had a
loss function J and we're wanting to
work out the gradient with respect to
our current theta parameters of the loss
function then we want to sort of
subtract a little multiple of that given
by the learning rate from our current
parameters to get updated parameters and
if we repeatedly do then stochastic
gradient descent will have better and
better parameters which give higher
probability to the things that we're
actually observing in our training data
and so the thing we want to know is well
in general how can we do this
differentiation and work out the
gradient of our loss function and so I
sort of wanted sort of this the
remaining time in this lecture go
through how we can do that by hand using
math and then that'll lead into sort of
discussing and more generally the back
propagation algorithm for the next one
okay so if we're doing gradients by hand
while we're doing multi variable
calculus multivariable derivatives but
in particular normally the most useful
way to think about this is as doing
matrix calculus which means we're
directly working with vectors and
matrices to work out our gradients and
that that's normally sort of much faster
and more convenient for some
rising annual Network layers than trying
to do it in a non victories duay but
that doesn't mean that's the only way to
do it if you're sort of confused about
what's going on sometimes thinking it
through in the non vectorized way it can
be a better way to understand what's
going on and make more progress so like
when last time I did the word to Vic
derivatives when I was writing to small
on that board sorry that was doing it in
a non victories way of working out the
weights talking about them individually
but here we're going to do it with
vectors and matrices and again look for
the lecture notes to cover this material
in more detail in particular so that no
one misses ed I'm let me just clarify
what I mean by lecture notes so if you
look at the course syllabus on the
left-hand column
there's the slides that you can download
and I'm straight under the slides it
says lecture notes that's what I'm
meaning by the lecture notes in the in
the middle column it then has some
readings and actually there are some
different additional things there that
cover similar material so there's so
there will they might be helpful as well
but that's the thing that's closest to
what I'm about to present it's the
lecture notes that appear immediately
under the slides link okay
so my hope here my hope here is the
following if you can't remember - how to
do single variable calculus sorry you're
basically sunk and may as well leave now
I'm assuming you know how to do single
variable calculus and I'm assuming you
know what a vector and a matrix is but
you know I sort of hope that even if you
never did multivariable calculus or you
can't remember any of it it's sort of
for what we have to do here not that
hard and you can do it so here's what
what you do right so if we have a simple
function f of X equals x cubed right
it's gradient and so the gradient is the
slow
right it's saying how steep or shallow
is the slope of something and then we
and also saw the direction of slope when
we go into multiple dimensions its
gradient is just its derivative so it's
derivative is three x squared so if
you're at the point x equals three that
you know there's this 27 of slope eNOS
it's very steep okay so well what if we
have a function with one output but now
it has many inputs so that we're sort of
doing that sort of function that was
like the dot products where we're doing
the sort of U TV or WT x to calculate a
value well then what we're going to
calculate is a gradient which is a
vector of partial derivatives with
respect to each input so you take the
slope of the function as you change X 1
the slope of the function as you change
X 2 through the slope of the function as
you changed X N and each of these you
can just calculate as if you're doing
single variable calculus and you just
put them all in a vector and that's then
giving you the gradient and then the
gradient and multi-dimensional space is
then giving you the direction and slope
of the sort of a surface that touches
your multi-dimensional F function ok so
that's going a bit scarier but it gets a
little bit scarier than that because if
we have a neural network layer we then
have a function which will have n inputs
which in the input neurons and it will
have M outputs so if that's the case you
then have a matrix of partial
derivatives which is referred to as the
Jacobian so in the Jacobian you're sort
of taking these partial derivatives with
respect to each output along the rows
and with respect to each input down the
columns and so you're getting these M by
n partial derivatives
considering every combination of an
output and an input but again you can
fill in every cell of this matrix just
by doing single variable calculus
providing you don't get yourself
confused okay then we already saw when
we're doing word to vac that sort of a
central tool that we have to use to work
out to work out our derivatives of
something like a neural network model is
we have a sequence of functions that we
run up one after another so in a neural
network you're sort of running a
sequence of functions one after another
so we have to use the chain rule to work
out derivatives when we compose
functions so if we have one variable
functions so we have Z equals 3 y and y
equals x squared if we want to work out
the derivative of Z with respect to X we
say AHA that's a composition of two
functions so I use the chain rule and so
that means what I do is I multiply the
derivative so I take DZ dy so that's 2x
wait sorry I said that wrong right
it's my example wrong oh yeah right DZ
dy so ya DZ dy it's just three that's
all right that's the derivative of the
top line and then dy DX is 2x and I
multiply those together and I get the
answer but the derivative of Z with
respect to X is 6x ok this bit bin gets
a little bit freakier but it's true if
you have lots of variables at once you
simply multiply the jacobians and you
get the right answer so if we're now
imagining our neural net well sort of
this is our typical neural net right so
we're doing the neural net layer where
we have our weight matrix multiplied
their input vector plus the bias and
then we're putting it through
and non-linearity and then if we want to
know what's the partials of H with
respect to X we just say huh it's a
function composition so this is easy to
do we work out our first Jacobian which
is the pass rules of H with respect to Z
and then we just multiply it by the
partials of Z with respect to X and we
get the right answer
easy
so here's sort of an example Jacobian
which is a service special case that
comes up a lot so it's just good to
realize this one which we'll see with
our neural net so well one of the things
that we have of these element-wise
activation functions so we have h equals
f of z so what is the partial derivative
of H with respect to Z well the thing
remember that we sort of apply this
element-wise they're actually saying H I
equals F of Z I so you know formally
this function has n inputs and an output
so it's partial derivatives are going to
be an N by n Jacobian but if we think
about what's happening there what we're
actually going to find is sort of when
we're working out the terms of this so
we're working out how does f of Z I
change as you change Z J well if J is
not equal to I it's going to make no
difference at all right so if my F
function is something like putting it
through the logistic function or
anything else absolute valuing a number
it's going to make no difference to the
calculation of F of Z I if I change Z J
because it's just not in the equation
and so therefore the only terms that are
actually going to occur and be nonzero
are the terms where I equals J so for
working out these partial derivatives if
I does not equal J it's 0 if I does
equal J
we have to work out as single variable
calculus what's the derivative of the
activation function for and so this is
what our Jacobian looks like for an
activation function
it's a diagonal matrix everything else
is zero and we've got this activation
function we work out its derivative and
then we calculate that for the
difference we have it for the different
kind of zi values okay
so that's a jacobians for an activation
function what are the other main cases
that we need for a neural network and
these are gone through a little bit more
slowly in these same lecture notes but
they're kind of similar to what we saw
in the very first class so if we are
wanting to work out the partial
derivatives of W X plus B with respect
to X what we get is W and if we want to
work out the partial derivative of W X
plus B with respect to B that's means
that we get an identity matrix because B
is sort of like a 1b right it's this
almost always on vector so you're just
getting the ones coming out to preserve
the B this was the case that we saw when
we were doing the word vectors that if
you have a vector dot product of U and
age and you say what's the partial
derivatives of that with respect to U
then you get out H transpose if you
haven't seen those before
look at the lecture note handouts and
see if you can compute them and they
make sense at home but for the moment
we're going to believe those and use
those to see how we can then work out
derivatives inside in your network
okay so here's this same neural network
we saw before so we have a window of
words we're looking upward vectors we're
putting it through a hidden layer and
then we're just doing a vector model
vector dot product yet this final score
and so what we want to do to be able to
train our neural network is we want to
find out how how s changes depending on
all the parameters of the model the X
the W the be the U and so we want to
work out partial derivatives of s with
respect to each of those because we can
then work out okay if you move B up the
score gets better which is good if it's
actually a Paris in the middle and
therefore we will want to nudge up
elements of B appropriately okay and so
I'm just doing the gradient with respect
to the score here and I skipped over
those couple of slides so if you just
sort of staring at this picture and say
well how do I work out the partial
derivatives of s with respect to B
probably doesn't look obvious so the
first thing you that you want to do is
sort of break up the equations into
simple pieces that compose together
right so you have the input X and then
that goes into Z equals W X plus B and
then you compose that with the next
thing so H equals F of Z our activation
function and then this H goes into the
next thing of s equals u th so we've got
these sequence of functions and pretty
much you want to break things up as much
as you can I mean I could have broken
this up even further I could have said Z
1 equals W X Z equals Z 1 plus B it
turns out that if you've just got things
added and subtracted you can sort of do
that in one step because there's sort of
pathways separate and there when doing
the derivatives but sort of anything
else that composes together you want to
pull it
for the pieces okay so now a neural net
is doing a sequence of function
compositions and when we say okay we
know how to do that the chain rule so if
you want to work out the partial of s
with respect to B it's just going to be
the product of the derivatives of each
step along the way so it's going to be
the partial of this with respect to H
times H with respect to Z times Z with
respect to B and that will give us the
right answer so then all we have to do
is actually compute that so I think this
just sort of shows okay we're taking the
partial sweet step of that composition
okay so now we want to compute that and
so this is where I'm going to sort of
use the jacobians that I sort of
asserted without much proof on the
preceding slide okay so first of all we
have D sdh well that's the dot product
of two vectors so the the Jacobian for
that is just H transpose okay that's a
start then we have H equals F of Z well
that's the activation function so the
Jacobian of that is this diagonal matrix
made of the element wise derivative of
the function f and then we have the
partial of Z with respect to B and
that's the bit that comes out as the
identity matrix and so that's then
giving us our calculation of the partial
of s with respect to B and so we can see
that the the identity matrix sort of
goes away so we end up with this
composition of H T times F prime of Z
okay suppose we then want to go on and
compute now the partial of s with
respect to W well our starting off point
is exactly the same chain rule that we
work
each of the stages so that first of all
you're working at the Z from the W X
part then putting it through the
non-linearity then doing the dot product
of the vectors so that part is the same
and what you should notice is that if
you compare the partial of s with
respect to W versus s with respect to B
most of them are the same and it's only
the part at the end that's different and
that sort of makes sense in terms of our
neural net right that when we had our
neural net that the W and the B were
coming in here and once you've sort of
done some stuff with them you're putting
things through the same activation
function and doing the same dot product
to create a score so you're sort of
doing the same calculations that you are
then composing with so it sort of makes
sense that you should be getting the
same derivatives that are occur same
partial derivatives that occurring at
that point and so effectively you know
these partial derivatives correspond to
the computations in the neural network
that are above where W and B are and so
those are commonly referred to as Delta
note Delta which is different from
partial derivative D and so Delta is
referred to as the error signal a neural
network torque so it's the what you're
calculating as the partial derivatives
above the parameters that you're working
out the partial derivatives with respect
to so a lot of the secret as we'll see
next time a lot of the secret of what
happens with back propagation is just we
want to do efficient computation in the
sort of way that's computer science
people like to do efficient computation
and so precisely what we want to notice
is that there is one error signal that
come
from above and we want to compute at
once and then reuse that when
calculating both partial derivatives
with respect to W and with B okay so
there are sort of two things to still do
so one is well it'd be kind of useful to
know what the partial derivative of s
with respect to W actually looks like I
mean is that a number vector a matrix a
three-dimensional tensor and then we
actually want to work out its values and
to work out its values we're going to
still have to work out the partial
derivative of Z with respect to W but if
first of all we just try and work out
its shape what kind of shape does it
have and this is actually sort of a bit
tricky and is sort of a dirty underbelly
of doing this kind of matrix calculus so
since our weight vector is an N by M
matrix the end result of the partial of
s with respect to W is we have a
function with n times M inputs all of
the elements of W and simply one output
which is our score so that makes it
sound like according to what I said
before we should have a 1 by n times m
Jacobian but it turns out that's not
really what we want right because what
we wanted to do is use what we calculate
inside this stochastic gradient descent
update algorithm and if we're doing this
we'd sort of like to have the old white
matrix and we'd like to subtract a bit
format to get a new weight matrix so
it'd be kind of nice if the shape of our
Jacobian was the same shape as W and so
we we and in general what you always
want to do with neural nets is follow
what we call the shape convention which
is we're going to sort of
represent the jacobian so it's in the
same shape as the inputs and this whole
thing is kind of the bad part of the bad
part of doing matrix calculus like
there's a lot of inconsistency as to how
people represent matrix calculus that in
general if you just go to different
fields like economics and physics some
people use a numerator convention some
people use a denominator convention
we're using neither of those we're going
to use this shape convention so we match
the shape of the input so it makes it
easy to do our weight updates ok so
right so that's what we want the answer
to look like so then the final thing we
need to do to work out and the partial
of s with respect to W is we have the
error signal Delta that's going to be
part of the answer and then we want to
work out the partial of Z with respect
to W well what's that going to be well
it turns out and I'm about to be Saved
by the Bell here since I'm down to two
minutes left it turns out that what we
end up with for that is we take the
product of the partial the product of
Delta times X so effectively we've got a
local Eris's signal above W and then we
have the inputs X and we're working out
an outer product of them and the sort of
way to think about this is sort of for
the W's you know we've got the elements
of the W matrix are these different
connections between our neurons and so
each one of these is connecting one
output to one input and so we're going
to be sort of making this in by M matrix
of our partial derivatives there's going
to be the product of the error signal
for the but the appropriate output
multiplied by our input and those goes
give us the partial derivatives
I'm skipping ahead quickly in my last 1
minute okay so right so this is sort of
what I said have used the shape can
convince and I'm going to skip that
okay so I've I ran out of time a teeny
bit at the end but I mean I think
hopefully it's conveyed most of the idea
of how you can sort of use the chain
rule and work out the derivatives and
work them out in terms of these vector
and matrix derivatives and essentially
what we want to do for back propagation
is to say how can we do and get a
computer to do this automatically for us
and to do it efficiently and that's what
sort of the deep learning frameworks
like tensor flow and PI torch do and how
you can do that we will look at more
next time